as well as being bogged down in
elections it's the time of year when the
UK honors its war dead and the
sacrifices they made in the two world
wars when asked to go and fight the
Conservative Party now wants that
unequivocal support to extend to the
actions of soldiers in more
controversial conflicts it's widely
expected that in the coming days the
Conservatives will include in their
election manifesto a pledge to protect
by amnesty all British soldiers who
fought in Northern Ireland during the
conflict there including those already
accused of crimes the newly appointed
veterans minister in Boris Johnson's
last government said as much on Twitter
suggesting a new law of armed conflict
would apply on the battlefield and would
override the human rights acts to
protect soldiers past and present from
prosecution the implications are
politically volatile one former soldier
has already been charged and is awaiting
trial over the killing of civilians on
Bloody Sunday in Northern Ireland in
1972 would his case be dropped under the
new law that would be explosive in
Republican parts of the province already
deeply unhappy over the brexit I think a
lot of these things will depend on
political reality on where it sits on
the political spectrum possibly you know
Island is in play politically for all
sorts of other things but like a blanket
amnesty is you know it's a major
precedent because certainly births of
hope the new law would also provide
blanket legal cover for any British
soldier accused of a war crime or a
human rights violation in any recent
conflict in the Middle East or
Afghanistan who would it mean soldiers
found guilty of torture being let off
and as well as protecting rank-and-file
soldiers would also give cover to more
senior officers who gave illegal orders
I would say that the prime issue with
all of this is that there are attempts
to prevent those high up those with the
bearing the greatest responsibility from
being looked at
the law is aimed directly at traditional
conservatives who think the British
military has to obey far too many laws
while enemies like ISIL and al-qaida
don't follow any rules at all but for
all that there are concerns that
soldiers already accused of serious
offenses might simply be let off and
also how exactly military commanders
will interpret the new law on the
battlefields of future Wars support for
military veterans fundraising job
opportunities better mental health care
are normally uncontroversial and are
widely backed by the British public
blanket protection from prosecution and
abuse of power written into law may
prove slightly more difficult to argue
for Lawrence Lee al-jazeera
London